since 2013 FX is critically acclaimed
series the Americans has revisited 1980s
Cold War politics with a depth and
nuance usually reserved for PBS
documentaries the first season begins in
the early Reagan years when the Cold War
seemed forever on the verge of
escalating into a full-scale nuclear war
the show follows the lives of Elizabeth
and Philip Jennings to Soviet sleeper
agents whose cover is running a travel
agency in the Northern Virginia suburbs
near Washington while raising their kids
their days are spent booking vacation
packages and schlepping their children
to school while their nights are filled
with deadly honeypot espionage setups
the trails by and of close associates
and thefts of state secrets their
motivation in life not just in work but
their motivation in life is ideological
they are political beings of the kind
that you rarely see recent TV visited Jo
Weisberg the creator of the show and
Joel fields the executive producer of
the show and one of its lead writers to
discuss the genesis and meaning of the
series their thoughts on the Cold War
how changing technology is leading to
better television and what we can expect
from the series sixth and final season
which debuts on FX
on March 28th Joe you were actually in
the CIA for a number of years and you've
said that the agency of all things is
kind of like what got you started
thinking about doing something about
your time in the agency what was going
on there one of the things that uh I
sort of absorbed when I was there I
didn't think I was gonna ever write
about spies or anything like that but I
still absorbed a lot that came out later
so I I was very I worked with a lot of
people who were married and had families
and like me were lying to the people
around them and I didn't have kids
I wasn't married at the time but
colleagues of mine were had to lie to
their kids about what they did couldn't
couldn't tell them they worked at the
CIA until a certain point that was known
inside the agency is the talk when you
sat down with your kids and nobody told
you what age to do it or anything like
that you had to determine for yourself
when your kids were mature enough to
keep a seat
and then you sat down and you told them
what you really did for a living
and if you thought your kids were maybe
never mature enough for that there were
even occasionally some people who never
told their kids but that idea even even
when I was there I thought that was like
pretty intense and after I left the CIA
and sort of was no longer kind of a part
of that culture the further away I got
the the in a way I don't want to it's
not just that it seemed odd to me it
started to seem really like the most
emotional and dramatic thing and when I
was later gonna write a series about
spies it seemed to me that was something
that had never been explored and
something that could form a very kind of
almost like a perfect dramatic spine for
a television and then then you upped the
ante by taking Russian spies and putting
them here and said they're hiding from
their kids what was the starting point
did you have a kind of goal in mind and
then has that changed as the series has
developed over the years what happened
well it was 2010 if you remember a lot
of Russian sleeper agents got illegals
they're called really were arrested in
2010 I was working on a science-fiction
show called falling skies and I got a
call from some of the producers of that
show and they said why don't you develop
a series based on this thing that just
happened and I said I don't know things
aren't really that bad between Russia
and America I'm not sure that's really a
good idea but let me think about a
little bit and I started wandering
around the streets a little bit and
after a couple hours I suddenly thought
oh you just put it back in the Cold War
and suddenly that's a really good idea
and you make the KGB spies themselves
the heroes rather than the FBI or
anything like that and that'll make it a
very interesting twist and you really
Center it on the marriage about this
couple and about these things I was
talking about about the family a line of
the kids it's something you've got a
very new original show don't you enjoy
any of this sometimes this house clothes
all those beautiful shoes
it it doesn't make you bad at what you
do it just makes you a human being don't
you ever like it that's not why I'm here
but don't you ever like it we have to
live this way for a job for our cover
five miles from here there are people
who are living like you know how I grew
up
it's nicer here yes it's easier it's not
better
the setting it in the 80s I mean as a
stroke of genius you guys are both in
your early 50s so you I mean that's like
a period that you know extremely well
and we didn't know it at the time I'm at
the same age range we didn't know it at
the time that it was the last decade of
the Cold War but what I mean Joel what
you know in the 80s what were you think
where did you care about the Cold War at
that point or you know where were you
more into parachute pants and you know
the BAM Living Color or something like
that
at hair product boy don't don't ask my
mom for the photos but they do not
involve parachute pants I remember
really hoping that we didn't all blow
each other up and it's been hard to
explain to some of the writers on the
show over the years that there was a
time when we really felt like we were on
the verge of thermonuclear Armageddon
and the day after
remember played a prominent role in the
show itself Testament was a big movie at
the time and the day after was a TV
movie about what happened if there was a
kind of exchange of nuclear weapons and
and then after that there was a panel
with but it was like le vis L and
William F Buckley Jr and people
discussing what it would be alive that's
right it was in touch it was a huge Jim
and the day after was a huge national
event it became part of our show the
families experiencing it but it was
certainly I think I know for both of us
because we talked about it it was a it
was a pivotal thing for Austin for the
nation and you asked what was it like to
be young at that time that that looming
sense of the Cold War as a real threat
boy it was a powerful part of what form
do you one of the things that's
fantastic about the show is that it is
it's not by any stretch of boost you
know it's it's not some kind of a pad
boosterism of like America [ __ ] yeah I
mean after the 70s there was a palpable
sense that America was in decline the
Soviets in 79 invaded Afghanistan and
they seemed to be on the march Reagan
took office and was kind of largely seen
as a as a madman who was capable of
you know discussing limited nuclear war
in Europe and whatnot and his first
couple of his first few months or a year
really in office was kind of a disaster
he got a lot of things done but the
economy was still tanking but then very
quickly America was back what were the
tensions on the Soviet side obviously by
the end of the decade everything had
gone to hell for them but you know what
what was the 80s like for Soviet people
well I mean that was an incredible
decade for them you know in the in the
early 80s up through when Gorbachev came
to power in 80 there was a kind of a
stasis and a you know kind of economic
malaise and decline but I don't think we
were aware of it to that much of a
degree we still felt incredibly
threatened by them as they went through
the final years of Brezhnev and Andropov
and and turn anko we weren't seeing them
as in decline at all and I think it's
hard to say what their own sense of
themselves was you know I think they had
to be on some level aware that their
economy was continuing to you know kind
of go down or not do very well but they
were a superpower and they were aware of
it and they had nuclear weapons that
they could challenge the United States
but obviously something happened they
had some level of awareness because in
1985 they knew they needed to bring in a
younger generation of leader and not
just that but one who was willing to
start embarking on some kind of change
you went into the CIA because you felt
that we were in a kind of Twilight
Struggle and that we needed to win and
that you saw things in very binary terms
the show certainly doesn't reflect that
kind of certitude moral certitude what
what changed I had a very
black-and-white vision of things I saw
the Soviet Union is an evil empire I was
a cold warrior I loved Ronald Reagan's
views on foreign policy when he talked
about an evil empire that resonated with
me I thought that's what it was and I
started to particularly after I left the
CIA I started to open up I think first
as a person in general as a human being
I started to open up and I think that
allowed me to open up more
politically and stop seeing once I
stopped seeing the whole universe in
black and white terms I was able to see
political the world of politics in less
black-and-white terms too and then a
couple of things happened at once one I
was able to go back and revisit all the
things I had seen and studied and
learned about the Soviet Union again and
start to see them differently and then
two I started to learn new things about
the Soviet Union and seen them now with
a new open mind everything started to
look differently so instead of seeing
this sort of simplistic evil empire
totalitarian society where everybody was
repressed and the Communist Party the
government were just these you know
terrible people and everybody there
suffered I started to see a real society
a real place with real complexity and
many layers of society with many people
who felt many different ways and had
many different experiences just like
really any large society like our
society as well and so I just started to
not have those simplistic views anymore
it's a weird irony of kind of 1980s
discourse conservative discourse
certainly that the government the
American government was always
inefficient and kind of stupid Reagan
famously said government isn't the
solution government is the problem
but then when we talked about the Soviet
Union it was a well-oiled machine
nothing nothing ever went wrong and
everything happened according to what
they planned you know in the eighties if
you said anything that equated the
America the United States with the
Soviets you were morally bankrupt you
were a relativist you know to make any
kind of similarities the series though
and one of the things that's rich about
it is that there's all of these
parallels you don't obviously Soviet
spies FBI counterintelligence people
even the opening of the show begins with
the kind of scenes from a Soviet
childhood in an American childhood I
mean do you see the systems as kind of
morally equal that's a great great
question yeah for me no it's not at all
about moral equivalence it's about human
equivalent
and I think that's what I'd be
interested to see whether Joe feels the
same way after all these years of
working together because nobody's ever
quite asked that question but to me it's
actually really important not to get not
to confuse human equivalents with moral
equivalence there are better and worse
ways for human beings to experience the
world and there are better and worse
systems and we can argue and about those
and test those and see how they function
in the world but what they're and there
are different kinds of people but all
people are human and I think that's
what's been exciting about to explore in
the show
everybody's got a everybody who has a
family has a family and everybody's in a
marriage struggles with marriage it may
be in their own individual ways but
there's a universality to the human
experience whether whether or not you're
a deep-cover Soviet agent or an American
counterintelligence officer those two
characters they should be the most
different but at their core they're
still human and exploring that is it is
it the heart of things for us yeah and I
mean I think this is something that now
you know that the 80s and the end the
Cold War passed a little bit we can
actually explore that rather than
worrying that we're getting a little bit
too soft on communism to go to your
point Joel you know there there are
better and worse ways and I say I'm sure
we all agree that the broadly speaking
the American Way was superior because
but one of the reasons is it allowed
people to become more human and/or to
kind of express their humanity more than
a more rigid Soviet system but is part
of the part of what the show seems to be
about is that Philip and some of the
other characters from on the Soviet side
are able to express themselves more
freely in a in a kind of modern consumer
economy I think that's it's a very
complicated question you know there are
all sorts of people here who express
themselves freely in all sorts of people
who don't
certainly that society put a lot of
restrictions on how people express
themselves but there were all kinds of
ways that people express themselves that
we probably you know didn't quite
understand or didn't quite see that did
that did happen in that society too
but probably what is unquestionable is
that the ability to be free and creative
in the economic sphere and in the
scientific speaks fear sphere and things
like that allows you know capitalist
economy to thrive in ways that their
economy didn't tell you in terms of
getting to a better place for the human
condition the story is still being
written as we all know we read a really
interesting piece of research that
people are having more better sex in
East Germany then the next generation
did after the Wall fell and they
interviewed some people and one of the
interview said you know we couldn't get
good jobs we didn't have much but now my
daughter has all of these professional
opportunities and she's a vice president
of the company and she comes home and
she's exhausted and they have less sesh
you know husband having more sex life
than I had under under the condo this is
under the East German you know jackboot
so you know we're all still figuring
these things out I don't think we've
unfortunately haven't reached Nirvana
yet right level for sure do you think
though I guess in the long run did the
Soviet Union collapse you did it
collapse Oakland ultimately because it
couldn't produce enough blue jeans and
cigarettes for people did it collapse
because of bankrupted itself trying to
keep up with Reagan defense initiatives
I mean these these are to counter
narratives and and it seems to I mean it
the show is certainly not a political
treatise in any way I mean it's a great
drama because it is moving out from
individuals and the way they interact
but you know why did the Soviets why did
the Soviet Union collapse it I mean you
get me started on this I'll go for an
hour but I'll give you the short version
that I don't think it was about trying
to keep up with Reagan's defense
initiatives and and that economic
pressure from the West I don't think
there's any real evidence to support
that although a lot of a lot of
Americans do think that and well is it's
flattering to us it's flattering to us
right a lot of people want to in a way
think that we drove that to happen in
the Reagan's Paulo and by the way it
wasn't just the defense initiatives you
know Reagan
drove a lot of covert actions
specifically designed with a specific
plan to bring down the Soviet Union but
I don't see any convincing evidence that
any of that really was responsible for
it whereas Gorbachev coming to power and
making all these changes with glass
notes and perestroika to open things up
and change the economy seems fairly I
mean there's a clear story you can see
taking place there where society started
to open up people started to talk about
all the problems it opened up both for
both in Eastern Europe and through all
the non Russian Republic's for the
nationalist sentiments started open up
in those places to start to break away
and break free and for the economic
sphere as it tried to reform itself to
start to break apart in crumble as it
tried to reform itself instead and you
can just see how that kind of unfolded
in the country started to break apart so
here's another theory I like someone
once said that it wasn't Ronald Reagan
and nuclear weapons that brought down
the Soviet Union it was Aaron Spelling
and the VCR and just the fact that
dynasty became available and those tapes
could be shuffled around from house to
house once you start looking at that
it's a little harder to support your
Soviet lifestyle well let's talk a
little bit about the the marriage that's
at the center of the show I mean one of
the things that's really delightful is
that you know these are spies who are
like you know who's got the kids tonight
because I've got to go and [ __ ] some guy
to get information and then kill him and
you know but Paige has to be at a band
practice at a certain time where did you
know where does that come from and how
do you know how do you come up with
scenarios for that we really asked
ourselves a lot of questions about if
this were really happening what would it
feel like what problems would they face
what situations would they be in and
then just you know along with other
writers that you know tried to just run
the scenarios and so it really just what
we came up with you know there's a great
the kate head KGB archivist a guy named
Metropia stole the entire archives of
the KGB and brought them over to the
west so we had a really good resource
material they told us about a lot of
things that illegals actually did so we
were able to take certain things like
for example to the marriage to Martha
was built on an actual story of how KGB
illegals did not often but but a couple
of times very occasionally did marry
women in order to get intelligence so we
had things like that that we could build
on and we take things like that and say
you know well what would happen next
and what would happen next and we made
that stuff up but it felt real to us the
kind of long-term I don't I don't want
to say it's a plot arc it's kind of a
moral arc of the show and I and this
goes to some of the point you were
making it's really about the individuals
being committed to one another rather
than ideological promises how does that
inform the final season of the show
because it does seem and I don't think
this is giving anything away to say that
that you know at the opening of the the
season Philip is kind of done with spy
work his wife is not there are also
larger complications that come from
Gorbachev and Reagan actually getting
together to talk about limiting nuclear
weapons and whatnot but you know how
does that commitment to an individual
rather than an ideology inform the final
season we asked that question
specifically in terms of the characters
in our show and their ideologies but we
also like to kind of step back and just
look at it generally in terms of what
marriages are like the truth is we're
all spies in our own lives we all have
our secret in our lives and even those
of us who try to share as much as
possible with our spouses have a part of
us that we don't know how to express or
they gets repressed because we're
expressing so much and there's a part we
have to hold back so we all struggle
with questions of our true identity are
our identity with our loved ones and our
and our public personas and that just
gets magnified a billion-fold
when you're a deep-cover spy because
it's it's actualized so in this final
season that all comes to a head for the
characters who have to deal with it in
their careers as spies challenging their
loyalty to their family but also testing
it against their loyalty to one another
in their in their marriage and their
loyalty to their country and their in
their cor idealistic beliefs you know
you know understand that you know in a
way this this is a profoundly political
show but it's not political necessarily
in the sense a lot of what we've been
talking about about which country is is
better or how do the two systems compare
it's political simply in this or in
terms of our perspective it's political
in the sense that the two main
characters Philip and Elizabeth are
driven by politics their motivation in
life not just in work but their
motivation in life is ideological they
are political beings of a kind that you
rarely see they come you know all the
way across the world and started this
whole family and done everything for
political reasons their hearts and souls
are political so in the final season
when Gorbachev has now come to power and
is starting to change their country in
very profound ways Philip and Elizabeth
that are going to react to it
differently and so imagine how that's
going to impact their marriage and
that's really what the final season is
going to be about what do you what do
you think explains the appeal of the
show I mean the show is airing now at a
time when I don't know you know the
American economy is kind of messed up we
have a threat from Russia as well as
Communist China you know I mean there's
a lot you know we have a madman in the
White House etc what what what do you
think is appealing about this show what
does it allow us to do that you know
less successful shows down when you put
it that way it just puts me into a panic
you know I think clearly there's all of
that everything that you said but at the
end of the day for us it's the human
story and the marriage story and the
family story we have a great moment in
season one where we sent one of our
rough cuts in I forget which episode
Philip and Elizabeth had just done
something horrible honey trap murder
something
terrible and they had this argument
about how it went and we get a call from
the Network executive who gave us his
reaction to the episode and he said
you're gonna get a call later with all
of our notes and thoughts and comments
but I just wanted to tell you I saw that
episode and I thought that's exactly the
fight I had with my wife last night and
we thought okay now we're cooking with
gas because if we can take this crazy
spy story and make it about the
universals of marriage then in the show
just might be able to work we've talked
about the content of the show let's talk
about the distribution and the
possibilities I mean this is a show that
would not have been possible 15 years
ago 20 years ago I mean you're on FX
which is putting out cutting-edge
material on basic cable as opposed to
something like HBO and whatnot how have
you benefited from creative freedom in
in in order to tell these types of
stories just start to finish I mean what
you're saying first of all is it this
show won't have been on the air really
at any other time and we were able to go
on the air we were able to stay on the
air you know at the beginning there was
pretty not the highest-rated show at the
beginning and to some degree it was
never the highest-rated show but really
with just critical acclaim and then kind
of growing audience we were able to have
a full run of six seasons and also just
you know the support from the network
telling us do whatever you want to do
just make it a great show don't stress
out don't worry about the numbers and
that the it's hard to even express as
writers the the freedom you get from
that the feeling that instead of sitting
there panicking about we have to do this
this episode or this this season to draw
to try and draw in more viewers all we
had to do was try to make it good and
that was by the way John Landgraf said
that to us he said don't worry about
anything just make it good and then
that's where successful life I tell a
story about John Landgraf actually and
explain who he is John like I was the
chairman guru head of everything at FX
couple deed to DT copy and but what to
tell your story about John Landgraf
who's the head
affects and something that happened in
between season one and season two
because you asked what it's like with
all this creative freedom and we do live
in a great amount of creative freedom
but I would put it differently I'd say
we have creative support that support
comes with freedom and it it almost
became a joke with us that all the notes
calls would start and finish with either
John or whoever was given notes they
would start and finish with them saying
that's your show these are our comments
take them for what you want but but you
make the choices you want to make so we
had that freedom but the freedom comes
with an incredible dramaturgical support
from them incredible insight and they
all spend a lot of time talking and
thinking about the show from a
perspective that we can't have they're
really our first audience and that's so
valuable between seasons one in season
two remember as you said we had
wonderful critical response season one
but not the greatest of ratings and we
had this talk with John Landgraf as we
were figuring out where we wanted to go
in season two and he said that he'd
given the show a lot of thought and that
means a lot because John gives
everything a lot of fun when he doesn't
you know a lot of that at all and
remember remember he said I've tried to
think about things you guys could do or
that we could do for the show that would
boost the ratings but I can't come up
with any ideas that won't ruin your show
and we don't want to do that so just
let's just keep making it good and that
was really liberating and so that's
again it's not just freedom it's support
that we had from the network a lot of
insight along the way from the beginning
really through the final episode but but
also the wisdom to let this show be what
it wants to be let me ask you though
because you more than Joe have a
background in TV and you've been in it
for what 25 years something like that
well my my post CIA cover runs very do
you do you think is it easier and it's
never easy to make a good show much less
a great show but do you feel like the
the medium has really matured in your
lifetime when you go back and look at
stuff you know I'm thinking of 25 years
ago I was interviewing out
as an entertainment reporter that was a
grandma not a bad show like it's not as
good as what we've got now well there's
look there's been a real cycle first of
all it's easy to forget all the great
shows that came before I mean we're here
on the shoulders of Hill Street Blues my
PD blue and some of the Norman Lear made
some of the greatest comedies ever made
so you know those that there was there
was great TV and and none of this would
be possible without it that said gosh
when I think about all the years that
I've made TV what cycles I've been
through when I started I started in TV
movies because that was the place you
could do really exciting work that's
where that's where the day after I'd be
made and that's where the brain bed had
been made and you could tackle important
contemporary issues you could tackle
important dramatic issues you could do a
romantic comedy you could do a thriller
and as I and I had a great time in that
world and then it's slowly kind of
changed and I cycled into the TV series
world but I never could imagine that
where the TV series would world was
headed was this incredible world of
drama when I when I pivoted the TV
series I hope to work on good ones but
the really great dramas were being made
in feature films and today we're very
lucky suddenly we found ourselves in
this place where when we started making
the Americans we were trying to figure
out what the stories were week to week
and by the time we got to the second
year we found ourselves letting go of
the week-to-week storytelling and just
telling this long story
following the drama of these characters
and there was this total liberation that
came with where we happened to find
ourselves in a landscape of TV so it's
been a pretty great journey do you think
that in a broader sense the type of show
that you're talking about here which is
you know this incredibly rich and
complex multi-layered story that unfolds
over years is that kind of serial TV
playing the role that the novel might
have in 19th century in 19th century
Europe in America of you know this thick
slice of a whole society in the way that
it's
together and if that's true you know why
why are we you know why are we watching
now rather than reading and and what
what is gained and what is lost in that
transition it's interesting I mean this
show does feel novelistic to me at least
you know specifically in the sense that
it doesn't feel it feels leisurely in
its pacing it doesn't feel like it has
to get anywhere it doesn't you know some
novels have cliffhangers and some don't
but this one doesn't feel like it has to
do every scenes it doesn't have to end
and in a certain place it just sort of
in particular its character based and it
just goes on telling the lives of these
characters and it could end anywhere now
by the way again all novels aren't that
way that way but some certainly are and
this show has always felt like that from
from the beginning but but but why
there's why there's a move to that or
why that's becoming such a popular form
of storytelling right now I don't know I
can only tell you that I found something
very interesting for myself which is
I've always been a big reader and I find
myself now going back and forth in
phases I find myself having a heavy TV
phase or I'll watch a lot of serialized
TV and then I'll stop watching TV and
start reading books again and then I'll
go back to TV and back to books and I
can't figure out what any of it means I
think one reason for that may be
technological my 15 years ago you
couldn't do that you had to watch the
shows when they were on the option
wasn't there of getting into something
and just binging it you know I think
it's actually changed the process for us
in a different way which is when we make
the show there's less of a creative
feeling that it has to achieve something
you know in a particularly urgent way
that's gonna get everybody to scramble
to watch the next episode but that we
can tell the story that feels right to
us and if somebody finds the show in two
years or in five years or in 10 years
it's going to be there and and knowing
that is very reassuring and I think it
does impact the storytelling them in
that's a related thing is that we're not
really under pressure to bring the
episodes in at a particular length we
can pretty much
as long as we want in any episode and
that is fantastic that really allows us
to just do what we want in the episodes
it's great as a kind of final question
you have created this incredible world
and you know it's it's a world that
people can recognize because we kind of
lived in it but it's a fictional
universe that is you've mapped an
incredible detail and nuance and
sophistication and it's kind of a great
place to hang out it's true you know
sometimes you want to be like okay I got
to go step outside and take a deep
breath or you know snort some cocaine
and clear my head
but what is it like to walk away from
that I mean at the end of this is it
hard to say okay we're shutting the door
here it's horrible we're like suffering
with that right now or suffering with it
I mean just just yesterday we watched
them filming literally last scene of the
show except we're still filming for two
more weeks because you know we don't
shoot the scenes in order so now even
that is so weird and so confusing and in
a couple weeks that world is closing its
doors I'm dying I know yeah it's tough
and emotional literally across the
street they're tearing down our sets
right now as we speak and it's been it's
been such a wonderful and gratifying
experience been a gratifying experience
creatively and personally and I'm just
in denial but it's I'm just gonna hang
on to denial as long as possible and and
keep making the show so you're all G for
making the Americans oh yes we will
definitely have nostalgia for making the
Americans hey maybe our next show will
be about making the Americans you think
that's kind of a universal nostalgic
thing I mean okay well we'll leave it
there we've been talking with Joel
fields and Joe Weisberg the creator's
showrunners of the Americans whose final
season starts at the end of March on FX
network guys thanks for talking thank
you thank you for a reason I'm Nicolas
you
[Music]